uh he he will not be
otherwise mentioned in this segment
because no offensive lineman has ever
even seriously been considered for the
nfl mvp award but like you can on so
many other things you can wager on who
will be the mvp in the states where
that's legal and that the number of
states is growing the fanduel official
sports book has put out the odds for the
2019 mvp award and at the top of the
list to no surprise patrick holmes at
six to one i don't like that bet though
because i think the chiefs may take a
step back offensively i think defenses
are going to figure out or at least try
to figure out how to slow down mahomes
and typically right mvp the best
quarterback on the best team are we
convinced the chiefs are going to be the
best team in the regular season this
year i think that that's going to be a
tall order chris yeah no not necessarily
i certainly think it'll be a little
different year especially with the tyree
kill situation and of course the
bull's-eye on their back a little bit
but i don't know i mean i think if you
made me bet money right now and you're
like chris you gotta pick someone to win
mvp i'm still gonna pick patrick mahomes
i do i just think with the talent level
still having sammy watkins and some of
the other you know travis kelsey and
other receivers they got there with andy
reid i still think they're gonna sling
the ball all around the field so he
certainly would be still my leader i
look at it that way i understand andrew
luck being second i think that you know
when i first saw it i was like oh i was
surprised but i get it i mean again
there's a team that's ultra talented we
know they're on the rise they made some
good improvements to their roster on the
offensive side of the ball where i think
his stats will continue to improve
because of draft picks like paris
campbell or devon functions being signed
in free agency at the wide receiver
position
i like carson wentz at 16-1 because look
if
if i knew he was going to be healthy and
if we all knew he was going to be
healthy all year long he'd be six to one
or five to one or four to one he would
have won it in 2017. he's got to show he
can stay healthy into december but at 16
to 1 that's real that's really the main
risk you're taking his ability to play
because when he does play we know his
ability as a player is going to be
second to none yeah no uh
you're right about that i mean hey
there's there's a lot of carson wentz
with that team philadelphia you're right
he's somebody i would like if you want a
good value bet i would say ooh that
might be one that jumps out to me let me
ask you this does it bother you that
quarterbacks are the only names on that
list really for the most part i mean to
me is that really what we've become it's
just the quarterback awards yes i know
yeah i don't know if i necessarily like
that overall for football i don't know
if that speaks to the sport
chris drive drive over to your home
state of new jersey and you can put some
money down on saquon barkley at 34-1
yeah
i know it's a great bet but nope it
doesn't matter the people who are voting
on it anymore we've just put the
quarterback like you said it's the
quarterback on the best team he's the
reason they win and there's nobody
nobody else is responsible it doesn't
matter anymore it's quarterback only
coaches don't matter receivers linemen
it doesn't matter quarterback is the
only thing that seems to be important to
a football team this day and age and i
just think that's a little crazy i get
it i know it's a a stat driven fantasy
football franchise quarterback league
but i do think it's overblown at at
times
do you feel better about ryan
fitzpatrick at 150 to one right daniel
jones at 2 50 to 1.
i guess if you made me choose there i
would feel
better about oh i guess i guess i would
say ryan fitzpatrick i don't even know
there i wasn't expecting those two names
to be thrown out of me there uh i guess
ryan fitzpatrick because at least he's
shown it to me before but i don't know
if i necessarily feel great about that
either what i'm shocked by is where's
like a dak prescott or ezekiel elliott
where are they at on the list you know
is zeke is 34-1 just like barkley and
dad and where's dak dak's not anywhere
there i mean we talk about teams zack is
50 to one wow 50 to one that's that's
pretty unbelievable so vegas looks at
zeke as being the more relevant cowboy
there if they were to have success
they're going to give him the the reason
for the success over dak that that's
unusual is it but well but isn't that
how it goes though yeah
now look that rams game from last year
may have been the thing that tells us
otherwise the rookie
i mean they're clearly the best player
on their team was ezekiel elliott and we
gave rookie of the year to dak prescott
that year going back to quarterback
it's ridiculous that's how ridiculous it
is drive drive the jersey and bet on
saquon and bet on dak although i don't
think we're allowed to bet not that we
would anyway well why would you bet on
them when you know it's going to go to a
quarterback don't waste your money i'm
not driving the jersey carson wentz 16-1
quick break more pfd live right after
this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports